ist halt einfach ein fallschirm habe und
der jonas wird einfach keine zeit wenn
ich jetzt hier bin ich einfach das hier
machen würde halt einfach auf den ich
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zurück zu gta 5 online zusammen mit
jonas und zwar haben sich ja manchmal so
ein paar leute beschwert wegen etwas
schlechteren qualität ich hab so gut
geändert wie ich nur konnte
allerdings liegt es ganz einfach an der
playstation 3 hat millionen ausgesagt
weil die ps3 1080i und 720p aufnehmen
kann und ihr müsst euch vorstellen dass
27 mini fans das thema so groß dass
1080p fenster sticker so groß also
deswegen viel bessere qualität bei 1080p
deswegen alle leute die ihn wie die auf
youtube machen sind eigentlich
hauptsächlich xbox spieler also in der
deutschen community deswegen musste ich
das auch mit diesem jahr das jetzt hier
aufnehmen
deswegen sieht das auf der xbox alles
viel klarer und besser aus was ich
machen kann es einfach ich kann man eben
hier noch versuchen was in den
einstellungen zu machen
anzeige ich kann eventuell die
helligkeit ein bisschen hochdrehen
nimmst es jetzt mit dem screen capture
von der ich nehme es einfach so mit
elgato auf mitgenommen also ich kann ja
auch nicht eine letzte qualität machen
oder irgendwie sowas bin kann ich gar
nicht machen das ist mir leid
ja keine ahnung kann ich kann ich auch
nichts dran ändern also das tut mir leid
ich kann das nicht passiert halt dein
maul und ein ich möchte hier hinein so
also ich möchte eine person mindestens
abschließend von hier oben
das geht eigentlich vor allem ich habe
von hier oben meinen kopf abgeschossen
und dann kam honorar das war ganz witzig
aber irgendwann kam dann willi und dann
könnten wir versuchen mit dem heli vor
dem wechsel das 1 1 ich muss erst mal
leute probieren sie von hier oben laden
beziehungsweise in oben ladenversion bis
heute zu killen von hier oben laden
keine seite doch du kannst du weiter ein
was man im alltag oder sein
hier liegt falsch vier minuten
fallschirm alter und schneidet in denen
schnapp dir dem wollen hält direkt vor
mir da direkt vor mir dann fallschirm
alter ich kann aber nicht auf den weil
ich hab halt schon ein coup optischen
einen hass mit airlines habe ich nicht
kannst du deinen droppen du musst den
auswählen und dann drei akten auswählt
kann man nicht auswählt toll auch wenn
ich mich hier drauf stelle dann könnte
ich leute sehen oh mein gott alter ich
liebe das risiko wie ich sehe noch keine
langen gerade kann ich dir gerade die
decke schießt einfach und außerhalb
ballast und die dann kommen dann balla
ich den helikopter dk ich sie sind viel
zu hoch es werden keine menschen geladen
das ist ein auto das auto angeschossen
ich schieße noch ein auto an ich hab ne
flasche lädt wieder nicht wenn ich das
was ich ihr vielleicht geht es auch
ich hab das auch
es lädt einfach nicht die sind einfach
keine leute es gibt es gibt ein grand
hier vielleicht kannst du nur mäßig auf
den krater stößt weiter auf den kran so
wie ich hier hatte ich guck mal wie du
bist
nein ich versucht doch mal bitte auf den
kreis zukommen
auf welche kran der da oben ist weniger
verdruss punkt ich fliege jetzt auf ein
anderes gebäude was ein ganzes niedriger
als der fallschirm
ich fahre hier wird so ein bisschen
gemein helikopter quandt ich darf nichts
mehr ram oder so 19 wollen jetzt einfach
mitten auf der kreuzung hierbei vom mega
angst lass einfach mit dem helikopter
zum flughafen fliegen und gucken ob da
noch kommen jetzt bist du blöd böse
erfahrung mit der polizei am start
da so drin
ja okay gut hass wegpunkt gemacht
manchmal wollen wir zwischendurch noch
beim waffenladen anhaltenden klingt ist
schon viele banken ist danach nicht mehr
schaffen erst mal die helikopter claire
mal hier die landebahn läuft tritt hier
walter ich hab richtig angst die kwl du
hast aber keinen fall schmidt ist wieder
raus springen kann oder soll ich schon
ich könnte wenn ich viel in bewegung
aber ich finde es auch so dumm über
wasserstoff man auch darauf cool wenn
man ins wasser fallen könnte zur über
minecraft ist nirgendwo die tochter also
sorgerecht kommt die bullerei also die
sache ist die ich meine lieben freunde
der unterschied zwischen dir dass du mir
ist einfach der dass trader sind
flugzeuge flächen des 14 es ist halt
einfach ein fallschirm habt und der
jonas wird einfach kein völliger seit
ich hier bin ich einfach das hier machen
würde
ich sehe im hintergrund so richtig
regnet stopp in diese studie kamera ist
eine treppe oder ich bin am airport aber
wenn ich da jetzt rein kommen konnte bis
zum airport das ist für mich erst ich da
erfolg ich meine ich damit flugzeuge
kommt man da nicht rein und kriegt man
halt nur allerdings da oben sind zwei
release am himmel
vielleicht aber hier die kampf gegen die
machen wenn ich ins runter und sport wir
müssen einen links hinten ein auto oder
seinen autos immer noch kaputt
diese flugzeuge sehen noch immer so
schön das ist man da rein gehen könnte
ich komme you to help ist hier diese
aber diese rampe so geil die muss ich
kurz froh waren ihr die die helikopter
ich sehe da kein bestandteil der
vorstand dennoch mal
ich mache eine kurve und drehen
bitte bitte da steht ein auto das ist
ein auto nein das ist kein auto nein ich
komme nicht weiter ich hab mal so ich
habe motto komm zu mir der waagerechte
wie ich habe 90 grad ich stehe hier 90
grad die wand und kommt nicht weiter und
ich habe direkten stern die bullen ab
ich hab mir den kopf ich hab mir den
kopf ich habe mir den kopf ich hab mir
den kopf an kopf rennen gleich den kopf
gelegt haben die kopten helikopter
tresor sterne
ich habe einstellen aber der ist weg
okay was soll ich tun kommt sowie ließ
mich auf der karte abholen und wir
treffen uns irgendwo an die nation
machst du irgendwie kann ich ja gleich
punkt haben weist aber du siehst doch
wenn ich ihn setzte
wir sind nicht im gleichen links dann
lasst den am nation neben der köstlich
ist auf der karte einfach nach rechts
daneben müssen deathmatch und einen
fahrer drin
solches wissen ich hoffe die polizei
sich nicht nehmen die sehe ich nicht
kommen hierhin siehst du mich ja ich
sehe ihren tod
hier sind so viele cops ich habe nur ein
auto was geparkt hat geklaut was gepackt
hat dann siehst du mich
kommen jetzt glaube ja der guard mann
ich bin fast direkt neben dir du
brauchst doch kein auto medica meter
komm jetzt iran ist ein einlaufen
skills unter brücken hier siehst in
waypoint nehmen
doch ja doch durchsichtig das ist
nämlich nicht ich sehe es schon kommen
ich kann ich recht gut fliegen und
witzigkeit wichtig gut fliehen
das musst du sagen jaja da hinten ist
unser und übte der macht zum bizeps
training im fitnessstudio oder einfach
schlägerei darauf her schlägerei das
sechste logo wird darüber sind ja ich
weiß was das bedeutet dieser typ auf dem
podest
nein hier sind emmi nation schaut man
landen auf glück hoffen kreuzung gilt
probieren
private
das den babba bisschen drei den 55
punkten ganz langsam schön
ich finde das gut so wartest du eben
erwarte ich eine waffe du musst wird l 1
auskennt dann auf die waffe und dann
drei lkw nicht wahrscheinlich ein auto
kann ich nicht kann ich nicht doch
airlines gedrückt halten
genau das hat die 20 jahre egal läuft
natürlich geben die nation
wenn ich mir das leid
du hast mich genug geld der verein bot
mit seinem wagen spieler
du hast echt nicht genug an befehlen
9000 keinen krieg geben aber nur das was
ich war bestimmt mehr als 3.000 4.000
auch mein grad etwas duran geht müssen
wir zur bank gehen ja okay ist nicht vom
national bank okay das ist jetzt keines
er entschied sich zimmer und dann
gewisse defizite wie verflixt die kanals
ist will ich hier das waren doch noch
der kreuz und los wie stehen die alle
wussten die stadt mann du hast schon
statt
die hochhäuser dahin
abends geköpft
wir nehmen jetzt mal dieses kleine
hochhaus daneben
okay das mit dem kopf noch brenne ich
beginne aber nicht rein
was heute öfters darauf an die batterie
noch das dann eben das daneben das ist
ein bisschen erwartet die ehrenrunde
hier irgendwo schöne länder
natürlich ich habe jetzt auf jeden fall
keine habe ich einen fallschirm wir
haben ich hab sogar fallschirm das mit
dem parkplatz jonas david zutaten müssen
riesigen kopfhörer suchen magna
irgendwann hab ich dich auch gar nicht
gerade acht dies belege dass hier die
kommunalwahl ein helikopter ab navigare
wartet gleich zwischen beiden
hochhäusern dann ist da einer sein
siehst du mich du wirst an der ecke
da wo ich hin programm ist zugleich
eigentlich anderen durchkommen da hinten
ist ein es wäre ja auch drauf vorhaben
geschlossen
ja die skripte steigt einfach weg wenn
ich darauf dass wir schon angst hätte
ich noch mehr ja die dies lassen
helikopter kampf jetzt machen
bis zu einer fliegt daneben knapp
daneben
die sind einfach ab was verlangt sind
drei spieler alter bild sitzen die aus
der luft töten oder wartet entweder er
ist uns erst mal ein ding zu besuchen
anderen helikopter zu töten
wir müssen sehen warte schade ich mich
zufliegen
dann müssten müsstest du ihn ab
ballonflug er mit einem fallschirm raus
springen in den in der luft in den
anderen heli ihn noch retten und dann
alter geht das ich bin einfach mal loben
da wirklich gelandet
nein wartet man müsse jetzt kurz gucken
was machen jetzt den wurzeln ab einige
touristen
ich sehe auch keine anderen vielleicht
sind ja auch direkte der näheres werde
nicht gewinnen
er kann ein bisschen rum gucken
die splitter
einfach auf sie landen ein knaller
gestapelt aus dem politiker daraus
nichts junge du bist nahezu direkt
daneben erwarten besser ja
schon ziel
macht ja auch sinn wenn wir sie schießen
ich bin dann mal weg geführt hatte ich
habe schon ein paar geile missbraucht
hätten